[موسيقى]
من اريحا ينضم لنا صباح العربيه خالد
القاسم خالد يسعد صباحك انت اليوم حتعرفنا
على نموذج حي لاعاده التدوير مصنع لصناعه
الورق من سعف النخيل عوض عن حرقوه عرفنا
اكثر عن هذه العمليه
يعني نحن هنا في اريحا في مصنع بيبر الذي
يستغل اا مخلفات اشجار النخيل
لصناعه المناديل الورقيه وهو المصنع
الوحيد في الاراضي الفلسطينيه التي يعيد
تدوير
سعف النخيل للتعرف على مزيد من التفاصيل
حول هذا المصنع معنا احد ابناء مالك
المصنع وهو المهندس احمد سعاده احمد من
وين اجد فكره تدوير ساعه في النخيله فكره
تدوير الصعب النخيل نشات عن صاحب المصنع
الاستاذ طارق سعاده والديك همم من
المخلفات الزراعيه اللي كانت موجوده في
المنطقه الاغوار ومنطقه اريحا خصوصا انه
كانت هذه المخالفات يتم تقليم اشجار صعب
او رميه بجانب الطرقات لانه مكافات ما
كانت تستخدمه
فمن هو نشات الفكره وكمان الفكره نشات من
وجود كميات كبيره جدا من مخلفات ورقيه في
السوق استخدم كيماويه في الصناعه في
منتشره لا يتم استخدام اي مواد كيماويه
ومنتشره يتميز باللون السكري مش الابيض
المتعارف عليه لان اللون الابيض بيكون
ناجم عن المواد الكيماويه ونبيضه واحنا في
يمكن هذا بيقلل من تسويقه لانه الناس تبحث
دائما عن اللون الابيض الناصري
صحيح بس بنفس الوقت في بعض الناس او
اغلبيه الناس بتحب تدعم انه المنتج الوطني
والمنتج البيئي خصوصا انه فكرتهم مصنع
بس باختصار بتحكي لنا المراحل من ساعه ما
تفوت ساعه في النخيل على المصنع لحد يطلع
زي ما احنا شايفين واذا في مجال الكاميرا
تورجينا
في المرحله الاولى بتم جمع سعف النخيل من
مخلفات الزراعيه من المزارع عن طريق
المزارعين المحليين بتمشي شراء هذا صاحب
النخيل عن طريق المصنع المرحله الجايه
اللي هي بتنطبخ هذا الصحف النخيل بحراره
وضغط عاليتين لحد ما يطلع معانا العجائب
هاي العجائب بتمر في عده مراحل معالجه
لتنظيفها واستخراج الياف السيليلوز منها
التي تصلح لصناعه الوراء ما بنستخدم اي
اضافات كيميائيه في هذه المرحله وبعدين
نستخدمها الالات اللي انتم شايفينها
قدامكم عشان ننتج منها ورق التواليت وورقه
يعني خلينا نحكي انه ليس بجوده همم
المناديل الصناعيه ولكن في اقبال من قبل
الناس على شراء هذه المواد الصديقه
المتزايد الحمد لله في همم اعداد الناس
اللي بتبحث عن المنتج الوطني والمنتج
البيئي همم من ناحيه الجوده
الاختلاف الوحيد بين المنتج المحلي
والمنتج المستورد او المنتجات الصناعيه
الاخرى هي انه هديكومنتجات تحتوي على مواد
كيماويه بينما منتشره خالي تماما من اي
ضبط كيماويه بدناش نتحدث من وين اجتكم
الفكره بس كيف عملتوا تجارب واكتشفتوا انه
صحف النخيل يمكن تحويله الى مناديل ورقيه
تم اجراء عده بحوث والاختبارات في عده
جامعات حول العالم منها الجامعه العربيه
الامريكيه الشارقه جامعه شنغهاي في الصين
وعند الجامعات اخرى في ماليزيا والهند
وفرنسا وتوصلنا لانه صعب النخيل منتج يصلح
للانتاج الصناعات الورقيه لانه الياف اللي
اللوز المتواجده في همم متواجده بنسبهم
معينه تمكننا من استخراج هذه الالياف
واستخدامها في الصناعات الورقيه بكفاءه
عاليه سقف النخيل ما بتنتج منه بس الا
المناديل الورقيه همم حاليا احنا بننتج بس
المنديل الورقيه بس العجائن والبرد اللي
بتنتج عندنا احنا ممكن نستخدمها لانتاج اي
نوع من انواع الورق في العالم وراء
التصوير ورقه الطباعه همم الورق
دي ورقه تغليف ورق الطعام وكمان ال-
المحارم شكرا الك المهندس احمد سعاده همم
اذا نادين وسهام ومشاهدين الكرام همم صاحب
هذا المصنع كان اصلا همم التاجر مناديل
ورقيه وثم همم تحول الى همم
مصنع او يعيد تدوير سقف النخيل الذي ينتج
بكثره هنا في مدينه اريحا وفي محافظه
الاغوار التي تشتهر بالزراعه
النخيل همم يتم تدويره الى همم مناديل
ورقيه كما ذكر احمد يمر بعده مراحل من
الطبخ هو يعتمد على الطبخ اكثر من اعتماده
على المواد الكيماويه لانتاج المناديل
الورق
نحن نشكرك جزيل الشكر خالد القاسم من
مدينه اريحا هذه المدينه التي تلقب بمدينه
القمر